Nora you're right we are here in Barron
County Wisconsin I am so excited to be
here I'm standing next to the tree of
Hope why is this important this tree was
put up in the lobby by court employees
and Peter's going to show you from the
very top let's pin on down Peter it says
J a whi M E and Jamie's honor and the
thinking was that this tree would stay
in this Lobby until Jamie returned home
there were so many people who believed
she was actually going to be here and so
now the thinking is that she's back and
she's safe and sound their hope is that
she will come and see this tree in
person we will see so when Jamie escaped
on Thursday she had no idea where she
was or what she was waiting for outside
her home where she was being held in
Gordon Wisconsin
luckily very luckily she saw a former
social worker name is Jeanne Nutter she
was walking her dog Henry Nutter says
that Gordon is a safe place where she
doesn't even think to take her cell
phone before leaving the house sometimes
she says she doesn't even lock her doors
so when Jamie appeared loss and needing
help they raced to a neighbor's home to
call law enforcement in her first
sit-down interview Jeanne Nutter shares
frightening details of the minutes
before they made it to safety I was at
the end of my driveway and then I saw a
young woman who appeared to be in
distress she was probably about 10 or 12
feet from me saying I need help all I
knew is whoever this child is she's in
trouble what did you see that made you
think she was in trouble because it was
19 or 20 degrees outside and I only had
a sweatshirt on and maybe some black
leggings and I thought she was in her
slippers so I figured she left wherever
she had been in a hurry you know a lot
of things went through my head so I
quickened my pace and got to her and she
just sort of fell into me and said I'm
Jamie and I said I know did you
recognize her right oh right away
because her pictures are everywhere
then my CPS Child Protection brain
really just clicked in and I I knew what
was going through my head is okay I know
your circumstances I know what happened
to you I know the person you're with is
potentially dangerous my only
responsibility is to get you to us
place why didn't you take her to your
house it's too close to where the
alleged perpetrator lives it's only and
actually his property touches the back
of our land but at the time you didn't
know that was a perpetrator she told me
that's where she had come oh she told
you you know all of this happened so
quickly so in my mind I'm like don't
take her there it's just you and Henry
you only have one door it faces the
woods you don't see the road so did you
know the Patterson family or do you not
know this cabin where it was and she
pointed to it because you can sort of
see it from where we were so she named
him right then yeah so you know exactly
where that was it butts against your
property so you were thinking if he's
following her then it's just the three
of you right how are you and Jane
there's no way out if he's at the back
door
all of that was going through my head
and it was just like she needs to be in
a safe place your cabin isn't safe and I
didn't want her to know I thought my
place wasn't safe because I wanted her
to be calm I just said safety safety
safety and you know that's what we're
trained in social work kids need to be
safe get them safe first ask questions
later
I was not calm inside so I did not want
her to know that so I I just practiced
on my skills talk softly don't ask her
any questions there are only a couple
questions I asked her first of all where
did you come from and she told me I said
is he home and she said no I said is he
in a car and she said yes and I said
what color is it because I want if I if
we ran into the car I wanted to have
some other plan in my head it's that
quick thinking that helped bring Jaime
home to a family overcome with gratitude
Nutter and Jaime's aunt Lynn met for the
first time on Sunday you coulda said or
done anything and you did everything so
right and you got to meet the family it
was wonderful I can only imagine what
they've been through honestly I feel
privileged that I had this little piece
of you know the puzzle of finding Jaime
really she is a hero because she escaped
but really she ran into you first and
thank goodness that you were a good
person but what how do you process that
for your own role
that was my job that day was to dust off
your child protection skills and make
sure you got this kids to safety and I
just wanted her to know she was gonna be
okay no matter what I did that kid was
gonna be safe
Nutter said one piece of advice she can
give when you see someone in need do
something she said that she just felt
blessed to see that her actions helped
Jamie return to her family and start her
journey to heal and our next half hour
we'll have more of an interview with
Jamie's aunts and her cousin plus we'll
hear from some of the people here in
Barren who are celebrating her safe
return and right now let's go back to
New York and Nora I can't say enough
bravo Bravo Bravo about Jeanne Nutter
because she actually went to another
house before she went to the final house
there was nobody home but she didn't
want to alarm Jamie so she kept telling
her all along you're safe you're safe
I got you don't worry about it we will
be okay and she wanted to reassure her
that she was close and she was only
about an hour from home because she
thought that that would be very
comforting to Jamie imagine jamie has no
idea where she is
and Geney nutters at first to tell her
you're actually still in the state of
Wisconsin not too far from your house I
can't say enough
Angie Nutter is another is social worker
knew all the right things to say they've
been trained in this I mean as a lot of
the smart set exactly in many ways that
they found one another just at that
moment thank you feel great great
interview